I did so also uh seven years ago I did a
talk on this uh trying to place the
different context on a timeline and
seeing that
um what's actually going on and how the
moving parts are and how they relate to
each other so my goal back then was to
try to map it to history and see how it
affected each other and how it comes to
be the way it was uh back then in in
2016 I guess
so uh
and
I also try to argue that this Tech
fatigue concept that's it's a lot of
churn a lot of a lot of changes actually
comes from that in the JavaScript land
all of the explorations and iterations
and changes to API and to technology is
always historically happened in a user
land so for in in.net context for many
years you had this closed uh Source
ecosystem that had some sort of release
log every now and then and again but in
JavaScript land and in front end world
this was entirely different because
every Innovation happens more or less in
the open in user land so it's kind of
changed the dynamic so the conclusions
and the technologies that are the
outcomes of those iterations
um is comparatively what we'll see from
other propertarian libraries and
ecosystems but in in front end
this was happening in inducer land so
point I was trying to make was that you
don't have to follow on on all these but
I think this is about to change and I
think it has changed for the most so I
will argue that now in in
in later years even now 10 years later
uh or seven years later I was talking
about react then and we can talk about
react now so 10 years is a long time but
in this six or seven years that's passed
now there hasn't been a lot of talk
about tech fatigue even though it's been
just as much exploration just as much
iterations just as much many different
implementations there there's been but
it hasn't felt like such a churn and I
suspect that it wouldn't from this point
on either feel like such a churn so I'll
talk in this presentation just just uh
some about that so
this is an interesting picture still
because
um
not much has changed in reality like
broad picture stuff since that
presentation seven years ago if we're
drawing the timeline further out it's
still react that's the most dominant or
any sort of Library that's abstraction
wise architecture wise the same so of
course there are other as well but here
I'm thinking about the overall
architecture and the thought patterns
that were used in making applications
and in a sense that's that's still the
same
so
it seems like in in 2013 when when
um Pete hunt did a presentation on the
jsconf
um
in Europe I think
um he was having a talk that that went
something like um read thinking best
practices or something like that and it
turns out in my way uh in my sense at
least that now we see 10 years later
that same thought pattern the same
architecture is still applied and almost
every other libraries and and Frameworks
are still using that same patterns with
some sort of variations of course
and think about this this is actually
kind of major because
react and component libraries such as
react feels like a new thing but in fact
we have lived longer with react than we
have with jQuery before react gutter but
in contrast jQuery felt like an age or a
full-grown
personage because
it's had such a profound impact in how
we did applications
and it's changed the way we're thinking
about it
in the same way that react started and
did that tectonic change in
architectural thought patterns in 30
2013.
so
and what's interesting as well is that
all the libraries in the same sphere and
in the same in the same
landscape with the same with the same
architectural patterns
it feels like they get a lot of
criticism they get criticized a lot for
having changed their apis and having
changed in Exploration I think this is
the same thing we saw previously that we
get to see a more open
iteration and more open exploration of
apis and patterns so it feels like a lot
but in fact you can write almost the
same way of react today as you could in
2014 you can take the code from 2014 and
run it in the modern day react and think
about that it's like for more than
jQuery existed before this change we can
still have the same code and that's it's
a major feat in in web development but
it also means that there hasn't been any
large
Paradigm shifts since then so there have
been a lot of different
implementations and and good ones that
change
um variations of how we do it but
there's a difference between developer
experience and and Paradigm shifts where
the the former change how you work but
the Larry changed how you think and
since
I argue that since 2013 there hasn't
been a major shift in how we think about
producing software and producing web
applications since then
so even though there's a lot of
different Frameworks and libraries that
that change how we work there hasn't
been any other change I would think
in
2006 Gmail
launched their single page application
uh on on phones
and that sparked like the the dawn of
the single page applications I
in my book so
since then
everyone identified that everything we
distributed through the web should be an
application and everything we
distributed through the web should be a
single page application so that's the
tool and that's the hammer we used and
everything was a single page application
internets were single page applications
internet has every internet had like
functions and comments and and social
media aspects of it and of course as a
single page application at least
during those years of
from from the 2010s
so around
my figuring is is around 2015 I guess
we're beginning to think okay
let's realize not everything is a single
page application so if it's not a single
page application it has to be a static
page so from that moment on everything
was trying to be static side generation
generated sites
uh
we had some static site generation
before this but this is when it was
started to and the technology was so
that it was possible to use it as a
general purpose application thing but
then we had some issues with Dynamic
data and started experimenting with how
to do Dynamic while doing static and
that's an important thing I think when
we see to the Future in what's
what's the next Generation architectural
pattern
so the truth is of course apps are both
Dynamic and they are static and they're
everything in between
so
there's no problem created equally and
there are wildly different solutions to
the different problems
we often forget to address what kind of
solution we're trying to make so we're
trying to treat everything like in
single page application or everything
like status static sites today we use
terms like
CSR instead and SSG these are just
acronyms it's not important to be there
I mostly included so that there wasn't
anyone like oh but you forgot about
incremental static regeneration and
whatnot and that's not the different
different parts of SSG I didn't forget
it but it's too complex and too too much
but also it isn't
it hasn't changed necessarily what were
how we're approaching building
applications it's a step towards that
but it's a part between uh if we're
looking at the Specter from totally
Dynamic pages in single page
applications over to the total static
static site generation so it's a specter
and and it's it's somewhere along those
lines
so but again
I don't think these have dramatically
changed how we approach writing software
it has improved some of the developer
experiences that should improves some of
the Waves were working there are a lot
of tools that help us do better products
and compensate for the lack of support
from the different
outer rims of the of the specter
but this I think is also
um applicable to think about it in in
product management or product
development terms so there's a
fairly common model in product
development that's Double Diamond model
that's all about converging and
diverging in in Exploration and I think
what we're seeing again is
um continuous Divergent in in the
technology and kind of a lack of
conversions because when everything is
optional and everything is selectable so
you can select what you want from the
different parts it's hard to converge to
a common platform but I again
I think
um this is what we're seeing lack of
Divergent but we save a lot of
convergence
um but but again I think this is about
to change and I think it's about to
change because of three aspects The Meta
Frameworks and I'll explain all of these
and and go into the detail afterwards
but the meta Frameworks
is
um I think that's the main reason why
we're seeing more convergence because
we're getting more opinionated stuff
that allows us to enforce more
conversions
um and we'll look at the server client
relationship that's possible due to that
convergence
and then we'll see uh some more about
data loading and ownership of data and
state as a consequence of of
the relationship of server and clients
and we'll walk into this with the three
important W's
what why and how
So Meta Frameworks what even is it
this is a term I've heard I guess for a
year now uh it's kind of silly
um because what is a meta framework and
how is it not a framework spoiler it's a
framework
but
I think we're slowly
painting ourselves in a corner in in the
front-end world where we've been calling
what was actually kind of libraries
calling them Frameworks and suddenly
we're getting Frameworks that manages
those Frameworks and we have no way of
calling them or
finding a new term for them so it just
automatically instead of framework
Frameworks it's meta Frameworks I guess
but essentially it's just Frameworks
it's just baggage for for poor naming
from from from before and I think this
is more clear
if you see on some of the examples here
so on the left hand side is what's
kind of libraries but also Frameworks
and on the right hand side it's it's the
meta Frameworks as as complementary to
those
so react for instance has next yeah that
is remix things like spelled as swell
kits quick quick City you have other
things like Astro which is multi
libraries integrated so you can do
alpine solid reacts Astro lit whatever
and
bake that down to a common
um meta framework
and this is kind of interesting because
it tightens the relationship and gets
more opinionated and we'll see an
example of that soon but I think a
really good study case for this is the
relationship between react and next
because in this world we also have to
see what's the custodianship what's the
owners and what's the maintainers of
those Technologies so
um
here it's natural also to talk about
meta and versaille and
so it's not Loosely coupled
Loosely coupled thing because
it's beginning to be some sort of some
symbiosis between those Technologies and
between those teams and we can see that
first of all versaille has hired some of
the the core maintainers from from react
and also you see employees from meta for
instance referring to them as colleagues
which is a term I think is not use at
random I think it's very very like
it's they're starting to build some sort
of collaboration culture between
both meta and versaille and that means
that
not only is the meta framework
um taking the framework itself and doing
something with it but it's a tightly
coupled collaboration which can create
newer things
so when looking
back at this what's the advantages of
that
so you can do exploration in a much
broader sense than before you can do a
lot more things because you do you do
more you have the choice of changing
more on the meta framework and when
you're doing collaboration between the
framework itself and The Meta framework
you can achieve even more
so
you get more of alignment more of
opinions which was considered bads in
the front-end world we were proud of
having flexibility and having the Power
of Choice we can do whatever we want in
in front of me if States management
doesn't suit you do something else and
we still kind of have that but I think
there's a scale between flexibility and
opinions and opinionated Frameworks
so there's kind of a trade-off
but I also think that opinions here and
opinionated Frameworks allow for
enforcing a paradigm shift quicker and
more clearly than ever before so the
rise of meta Frameworks I think of
incubated this this what I think is is
tectonic shift and in how we think about
architecture
so one example this is the relationship
between the server and the client
again we saw that
over the years we've done many different
ways of doing applications from Spas to
ssgs and whatever
behind this is some sort of poll match
between server and the client and how we
view as the
main source of truth and how we view it
as
State machine or whatever so let's just
start at the beginning and see at the
jQuery model so back in the just after
the dhtml time
this is how we we used to roll out
Dynamic applications in web2o so you
send over some some
HTML from the server through HTTP most
likely from servers like
net or whatever or PHP even and you do
over the server and then you look at the
server Point select specific nodes
and make those specific nodes Dynamic if
they're changing you're changing only
that node and ignore the rest of the
page
this is this the traditional jQuery
model
so
when we're transitioning over to single
page applications or what's what we now
usually call client-side rendering
this is kind of different we're just
sending a blank page sending that over
the wire and build the application on
the client side so the client side has
now total control of what your
application is and if you're doing
changes there the changes happen on the
client side and essentially it happens
for the entire page
there are some technologies that
mitigate this but in in
[Music]
Theory and in practice it changes the
entire page every time this is also
another drawback of this is that when
you're having the source of Truth and
and the the original state in the client
you'll have to do a lot of communication
with the external and that's the magical
threshold of http
so over there even though we have local
servers and local whatever there is an
overhead
and especially with systems that are are
like um One Plus o of n
uh commands like
firstly fetch this and for every element
of this do this so again we can mitigate
that with things like graphql BFFs
servers whatever but in any case you'll
have to do a lot more information
gathering from the client over to the
server this is error prone this is
slower and there has a lot of drawbacks
there are some some advantages as well
of course but there are also drawbacks
so given those drawbacks
there have been a lot of service hide
rendering Focus so instead of doing
server-side rendering
um a client-side rendering exclusively
you do hydration so you're sending the
initial page
from before and then hydrate on the
client side and essentially from there
on out it's the same
so if you're changing something in that
you're changing the entire page and
again if you're doing a lot of
communication with servers and whatnot
you're doing a lot of overheads it's the
same from the point on uh after the
client has received the information
there is still the same drawbacks as
client-side rendering
but what we get is more robust we get
search mod search engine optimizations
we get easier support for for
accessibility so there are advantages of
doing this but still there are a lot of
disadvantages
so
a more
perhaps newer term is Island
architecture and partial hydration again
it's a couple of years old but it's it's
still fairly new in in thought pattern
wise but instead of
sending over and hydrating the entire
application again on the client side
you're just marking specific points from
your server and saying this this is done
the dynamic run everything else is
static ignore that and in this case you
only change the specific item
um that you have marked for this and it
also means that you you can send less
information from the server to the
client
because you're explicitly marking
something
as this is what I want to be dynamic
we also have something else that's
resumability it's a bit newer again and
and
um
maybe not as as known but it's still
used fairly widely in some circles so
instead of of doing the partial
hydration uh automatically on the client
side we're sending over static sites
and marking that this
when we're interacting with this and if
something happens uh like an event then
we're initiating the the dynamicness
again this is really a
like a high level walkthrough but we'll
look into how this is in practice uh
soon so if we're doing changes here when
we're interacting only those components
or knowledge those nodes in the Dom tree
is changed
well let's back to to partial hydration
first because this is the the start of
the tectonic shift I think
um
so if we're looking at this
this isn't
far off from how I describe the JK model
from so instead of having the client ask
the the
um
source of Truth and and the the original
data in the State Management we're
moving that to the server
this has a huge huge advantage
that's
instead of
crossing the magical threshold of HTTP
we're doing the entire application
fetching from different servers closer
to the server itself so we're reducing
risks we're
um increasing ability to
mitigate errors so it's more resilient
and
it's it can be cached in different ways
across different
users so there has a lot of advantages
in doing this and we're changing so that
not everything is on the client but only
what actually needs to be on the client
so there are a couple of implementations
of this with different semantics and
different ways of doing it
but I think in essence
the change in thought pattern is the
same so it's a shift from
a client first perspective to a server
first perspective and that changes the
entire way your mental model Works in
how you write applications so it's not a
developer experience thing it's it's a
paradigm shift thing
so here's an example in in next year so
next JS since
13.4 I guess has defaulted to instead of
using a client-side first thinking to
server-side First thinking meaning that
every component you write unless
otherwise specific specified
is a server-side thing
um
this is a pragma key over here with the
use client on the right hand side it's
not important the details here but it's
it's kind of important to see that it's
um changed how we structure and how we
think about it because again when it's
server side first it means that uh what
happens to Secrets what happens to
database connections what happens to
um whatever interaction with file
systems or whatever everything of that
is hidden away from this from the client
but explicitly where it says this is a
client side this will be transferred
over so it's a cleaner uh cleaner um
separation between where the contexts
are
in what context is thing running
so and also it's interesting to see that
this actually works by having you can
have children of client-side things that
are server-side things
it's kind of a track but essentially it
just means that when opening a server
page from this it starts streaming from
the nodes from top down so when meeting
a client-side
component it can have server-side asset
children not as com as a property but as
a child because it's uh streamed as text
input and serialized as a Json structure
so this is an example of of output in
the browser when running in a simple
example like I showed before
and again
it serializes the the HTML structure as
as Json and then outputs that specific
part of what is dynamic as dynamic
the other parts is just static HTML and
has no code
other than than what's outputted from
the server as HTML
another fine example I think is is Astro
so asteroids mainly a meta framework for
doing
static sites
but it's also kind of coined or kind of
popularized the term Island architecture
which is the same as as partial
hydration as I shown in in xjs in
essence
but there is a lot of it's a bit
different in how you use it in after you
have directives
and you have the separation between what
is run on the server and what is run on
the client so what is in the front
matter syntax here as it's probably seen
in things like markdown that's the
threshold for HTTP in a way so what is
inside the the front matter happens on
the server it just code behind if you
will and you can access that from
the code below which is outputted to the
server to the client again everything
you write in Astro for instance
here we can use react components and and
swell components as I said before but
and Astro components as a no as its own
markup language but
everything by default is server stuff
you have to explicitly Mark with the
directive
things like this client loads and that
says this particular case is dynamic so
only send code and client-side code
that's relevant for this component
everything else static ignore it but
this one this is dynamic
there are other directors directives as
well things like
um uh lazy or in view which is
treaties are static but if it gets
scrolled into view for instance
um then you can load the data so if I
think the prime example is a carousel
that's further down on your page that
requires a lot of JavaScript but only 10
of your users see uh just defer loading
of that
um to the bottom
again
the most important part here isn't Astro
isn't an xjs but it's
the default thought pattern has changed
from thinking how can we access the
server from the client from
from that to okay we're doing a server
here and some of our output is dynamic
flips the entire relationship
so
by default just server just output just
HTML
but some cases can be dynamic
um and some cases can be changed on the
client side as well
but that's opt-in instead of of uh opt
out in a way so there are also some
safety advantages of this like I said
um in previous implementations of next
where we're doing server-side
um
server-side rendering you can easily
leak API keys for instance because it
relies on tree shaking to to clear the
data from the different bundles which
means that if you're adding something
that's not tree shakable it can be
outputted to the client they had some
solutions where you can copy paste your
code and see what would be tree shaped
that's very cumbersome and hard to use
but this also means like I said Runner
is changing from thinking
client-side first over to server side
first this also means we're changing and
flipping how we're doing loading so
instead of trying to collect all
information to the client we have now
have more on the server
so this is what I mean about data
loading and ownership
so
when moving everything to the server
with with out normal hydration
you have to be dynamic still we're not
we're not we're not just creating static
Pages we're still doing still having
requirements of doing things dynamically
but
it changes
the structure of how you do it so I
think this is a May third major major
change that we'll see a lot more of and
I'll do some examples here as well so
this is from quick
which I believe is is a
framework created by one of the previous
angular people I don't know but it's
still
um jsx it reminds you of things like
react but there are some different
ergonomics but it again it doesn't
matter but
quick uses resumability so again it
changes that everything is static unless
otherwise told so but it does so in a
different way so I'll show an example
this given the but we have this counter
which is the classic example I guess
um we get this output
so plus increment a decrement and a
number this doesn't do anything it's
just HTML it just outputs HTML no
JavaScript whatsoever
with a few changes in the carryouts but
for point being is it's mostly HTML
but
look at this so the button itself is has
a reference to it and it has a odd
hashing or something that seems
oddly specific so
we can reduce these the example of this
to this
just ignore the fact that I've written
href here instead of button click but
it's the same principle so
given that you have an HTML output
they also include a global event
listener that listens to every click you
ever do on the web page and when you're
doing a click it tries to match and see
is this something
that I want to handle so when clicking
on that button
it goes over and importing using esm
modules an important importing that
specific file as referenced and that
specific function that is is exported
so in this example we can see that for
the first increment that refers to a
specific export in that module that is
dynamically loaded when clicking on it
so this is an example of the running so
we've seen that when loading the page
there isn't that in JavaScript it's
embedded in the page but when clicking
on it you get the
um this the function itself
but also you can ask them
doesn't it go against the principle I
just said of uh reducing the number of
calls this will maximize the latency so
every time you increase every time you
click on something that's intractable
you're downloading a small chunk of
something that's incredible incredibly
wasteful for for latency and overhead
and especially if you're not using
things like cdns and having service
close to your client but the way they
mitigate It Is by using service worker
so preemptively for every page you're
opening they're caching essentially the
every intellectual element in there so
if you see here it's loaded from service
worker instead of actually downloaded so
um
they're kind of mitigating that
instead so
the initial load will still load some
code but it's
um
when revisiting the site for instance
it's not not as bad
and but this is an example of of
something Quake calls RPC and RPC as we
know is is remote procedure call and
it's existed for for generations of
developers
um
so it's just the fact that giving some
sort of invocation or command at some
sort of service I'm trying remotely to
trigger that and get the result
of course in quick world this is just
HTTP but again HTTP
is some sort of RPC
you're executing a specific command on a
server and getting the results so this
isn't a fancy new protocol or or some
specific thing is just an import
statement referencing a specific type of
URL that's quick
as as constructed so in this quick
example we're still dynamic
um
the RPC is more how to load codes and
not State and we're in in this way we're
still having the state and the source of
Truth in the client side
not on the server side but this is an
example of how we can change how data
loading is we can see another example of
that using server actions in next this
was launched as Alpha for a month ago I
guess in in in
for next.js so it's in Alpha in next.js
13.4
again what I want you to take out of
this is
the switch between who owns the state
and switch between who owns the data so
this is obviously a ludicrous uh code
and and not something that's recommended
but it shows that
if we're doing uh
State on the server we can expose that
and handle that on the server side
we can see the running example uh after
a while to see how it works but
if we're seeing here
the output is just HTML with a button
and when trying to click the button if
we're adding a breakpoint for the xhr we
can see that when doing a bottom click
it just actually does a fetch underneath
to itself
in the same
at the same URL with something called
Next action with an action ID there so
this action ID
as sent to a header
is the same as seen in the HTML itself
and in fact we can see that this is
um just a form with specific IDs on each
button so when clicking the different
buttons
we can see that it works
but even though um and and we can even
disable JavaScript and it will still
work as as same intended because the way
the RPC here works is they identify what
is marked with the pragma key as you
server extract that as a separate
endpoint
in in the same file essentially so
instead of being a get request it's a
post request as uh
I think forms only support get them
posts maybe others as well but yeah
so then when doing a post request
through the form to the site itself with
the Header information or with the form
information of the button with a name
they can map it to a specific action on
the server side
so this is
um maybe a more
an other example of RPC but it's still
unpacked RPC and we can do server
loading with this as well instead of
just doing through a form where we can
get server information
where it then extracts as its separate
API a separate endpoint and then do a
post request or a get request from that
endpoint but in the code it seems like
just a function call
this is this is Major in a way because
this means that
interactions with data and state is
Progressive enhancement proof by default
because here I just I didn't write any
specific code for handling uh data here
on the server side or the client side it
just works without JavaScript
and there's not much points per se to
absolutely not support JavaScript
um
there isn't many doing turning off their
JavaScript other
it also means that if something fails it
can degrade to to a lower form of
working so we're building in complexity
um instead of instead of going
complexity first
this is of course not without its
caveats
so it can
one major drawback is obviously that's
there are a lot more there's a lot more
distance from what we're writing to what
we're observing in the client side
so before we're just doing bundling of
sites and we're having Source maps to
match from the bundle over to the actual
source code
when there's extractions and creating
different API points that we don't see
and it's abstracted away from us there's
a larger distance so it might make it
harder to debug
but the advantages are it's real closer
to real semantic coupling and and
coupling of data
so
complexity cannot be created or
destroyed only transformed from one form
to another obviously not true I create
complexity every day but also not not
true because I think often when we're
trying to introduce architecture to
reduce complexity
um
we're not really reducing complexity
we're just shuffling complexity around
and I think this is true for this case
as well because before we had
the major drawback of server client
relationship and server loading before
was that
um things that are supposed to be
semantically coupled
are architecturally Loosely coupled
so we're trying to mental model our way
around loading data
but now with this we're changing that
around to being things that are
semantically coupled
are actually technically Loosely coupled
because it's degrees of different
separations of
um
of how we're interacting with them from
protocol to protocol Etc
but again it doesn't reduce complexity
it's just a different type of complexity
and I think it's
um it's a matter of finding the
complexities and abstractions you can
live with
so I think those three major building
blocks
um now will change not only how we work
but how we think about building a web
web applications
so
if we make a large
a much larger gent in how we think about
it not only how we work with it so meta
Frameworks are more opinionated causing
it to be able to converge more and
enforce opinions a lot more it means
that we can see larger changes but I
think
maybe it was it will lead to lower churn
as well because we won't see the entire
exploration and iteration phase
and we see that the method Frameworks
uses their opportunity to do so and they
use their power to to enforce their
opinions as intended before I think
front-end developers was mostly against
having two opinionated things I think
maybe that's about to change
um
and and also think that seeing how
they're changing things and flipping the
relationship and server and client uh
um to being server first instead of
Client First it means that we need new
ways to interact with data we need new
ways to do State Management we need new
ways to load data and it changes who
retains the ownership of that data so
again it isn't without trade-offs
but the advantages you get is lower
timed interaction less transfer data we
get more robust Solutions
and
last but not least we get progressive
enhancements by default something that's
been been lacking for many solutions for
the last seven years
so one important part of this paradigm
shift
I think it's it's um
it moves kind of the the the way we're
able to evolve systems over time because
it's a lot easier to move to more
abstractions and more tooling than it is
to move to less so for instance moving
and going from a fully fledged single
page application over to a server-side
rendered Progressive enhanced Solutions
or a subpart of a solution as really
really hard moving from just uh server
generated stuff over to more Dynamic
subpart is much easier because it's from
a lower degree of abstractions to a
higher degree
so I think the movement here
to being server first uh is will be a
big part of the next generation of the
the server and the way we think about
creating web applications so it's more
than just server-side rendering and it's
more than just data but it's I think
it's building blocks build building on
each other to to converge a lot more
than before
also I think it's getting more polarized
in a way in what we're creating
um because
this we will still see these single page
applications we will still see the uh
static site generated content
um
but I think it's more important than
ever to to think about the
um
think about the advice we get and see if
is this applicable to my problem area
and it's disapplicable to me
um and I think we're probably moving
into a time that we'll see more and more
transition into server first thinking
but it will probably take a time before
it does so
that's it uh questions comments to
Twitter also I have two Norwegian
podcasts in in strange dialects
um so I mentioned all that so in Hope
for getting listeners
I think crucial thing
see that and send me a message if
there's any comments
well they're not I'm done
[Applause]